nell'episodio precedente veloce veloce
c'è qualcuno oltre a lui cazzo non aprì
la porta
dimmi che no no no no no ma che culo ho
trovato madonna che nascondigli prego ti
prego
porca [ __ ] altro che serie tv bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su al in
isole shaun ragazzi era un secolo che
non è un lo riprendevo perché avevo
perso i salvataggi poi mi son dovuto
rifare tutto fino a sto pezzo dove ero
arrivato l'ultima volta che è stato un
delirio ma ci siamo arrivati quindi
continuiamo perché ci siamo se mi
ricordo che ciao bello ascoltami c'era
un motivo se avevo smesso di giocarci
ascolta 0 ma lo sa che la mamma ha fatto
le patate a tavola l'esagerazione totale
comunque in esplosione
secondo me è come un cazzo un membro cio
vivo anch'io ha porto il casino che
sembra tanto soli e non muore mai si
vecchia pallottole esplosioni non crepa
impossibile scappa nuovamente non avrei
mai detto proprio una scala scala più
perfetto ma ovviamente dove vado io
sull'uomo
posso andare su ragazzi io scommetto
tutto quello che volete che me la prendo
un interessante non ce la faccio ad
arrivare la finta scalare è sta roba ma
seriamente tra tutti i posti che potevo
andare anche a [ __ ] dello scalo
ecco eva 66 stupida non è colpa mia
bello fantastico ragazzi come se non
basta come volete mandare anche godzilla
non sono giusto per capire non è che
cosa fai serio ma si ok ce l'ho fatta
non so proprio un cazzo sai che crepo
qui è stato bello
no non sono ma ce la sto facendo la
mente ce l'ha fatta
oh mio dio ho fatto un raga non so non
fate domande non ho idea di come io
abbia fatto questa cosa a me i biscotti
ma aliena morto la domanda del cazzo
appena fatto come se fosse impossibile
credo che non ma conterà madonna sta
scendendo all'inferno 2 ragazzo siamo
scesi due sono senso non posso perché
sono già al massimo fantastico e rava
cazzo giorno sono fottutamente vivo non
so come ragazzi ma va bene così alla
simpsons in ethics cos'è estero non lo
so è stato fottutamente fantastico è
stato assurdo
la taylor con le scorte emerse guasto
rilevato ma va veramente credete che ci
sia un guasto ma siete proprio sicuri e
trova un ascensore alternativi tanto io
ho già capito striscia nei condotti per
l'eternità possibilmente senza fumo
perché già non vedo un cazzo qualcuno ha
voglia di spiegarmi dove dovrei trovare
un ascensore alternativo in sto postato
la batteria si è scaricata già cinque
minuti di batteria mio credo che siano
in un futuro prossimo ci sono cinque
minuti di batteria nella torcia
fantastico proprio la tecnologia che un
pezzo del sistema veramente manca tutto
il muro zia prova che cos'è il buio sci
ma che bella persona che se basta tutti
i condotti non è possibile
dove siamo dove che sono spuntate a dico
sì ok mi piace ho fatto non erano vivi 4
secondi fa ragazzi a noi da 5 un dotto
figo dirlo prima modo cos'è o mio dove
siamo finiti a diso minchia che figo
ascolta zio attento quando cammini che
hai pestato qualche merda io dove posso
provare a sparare a un tizio per vedere
che fine faccia ma con kong aver fatto
che c'è una grata e non riescono a
sbarrarmi bene di tutti
amico mio hai visite ma che bella cosa
sto iniziando ad adorare questo gioco i
numeri
sta succedendo veramente lo stopper
della lega è arrivato di sotto anche di
sotto mettevano male pensavo fosse di
sopra che quasi un potevano essere
problemi abbastanza che non trova lavoro
[Musica]
a [ __ ] gioca a poker
il cazzo mi mezz'ora che fanno mezz'ora
che giro per i corridoi di merda non
avete idea anche se piuttosto di madre
madre quando 1.6 brutto che
sì sì il dentista tua lo conosciamo
tutte le strade per il figlio avete
presente quando non so non ho idea di
dove cazzo stona va bene ma che sorriso
e fiducia sta tizia trova un modo per
aprire il portello del deposito questo
tessera d'accesso ai a bassano testare
d'accesso però nicchia un mezzo dove
siamo chi è quello eccoci ok mi chiamo
zara piano adesso però semplicemente
devo far sì che lui mi apra la porta c'è
qualcuno no perfetto scotta zio mie mia
pista porta per farvi anni vedi livelli
a [ __ ] visto anche illuminando la
faccia anzi si stai facendo stretching
ascoltami zia posso di fare a rocky
balboa di un cilindro di comprare beni
per il a 1 che l'abi che segue sicché
subiti ma veramente che figo io lo
prenderei attestati in questo momento
che non ho paura di farlo poi magari si
gira male quindi per ora che così va
bene ce lo teniamo così i ragazzi scalda
se farai che ballo tipo quello dei daft
punk
diciamo la roba sia una cosa troppo
figlia e mi aprì questa porta per favore
grazie c'è mike hickey stava su stanare
prima potrà chiedere ai robot elia prima
un qualsiasi porta praticamente
fantastico bene bravo zio poi di al
calcio adesso chi prefetto 6 sto schifo
è roba ragazzi che io sto facendo tutta
sta merda tutta sta merda per trovare un
pezzo di ricambio bellissimo ok vado
subito però è tutto elettrizzato ma è
che passi prima tu e muori così almeno
fa dopo io poi ecco bravo vai vai vai
bravo così beppe
manovra forza ma veramente famiglia mi
dispiace troppo ma è questo qui si è
fatta mi sembravano essere tipo all'ikea
quando prendi le cose dagli scaffali o
meno uguale mio dio si sa se è stato
tragico miglia
l'abbiamo fatta ha dato c'è la russia
che dondola bellissima cosa vuole ok 40
minuti per aprire sta cazzo di porta
bellissimo va bene anche così e non vi
preoccupate orchestra è mai la stazione
della navetta assisi tanto ormai non
sono anche più cosa sto facendo quindi
va bene tutto sto casino per suonare in
un caso che figata pazzesca ma possiamo
tornare a te mi sono ritrovato so dove
siamo regala ai vai vai vai vai io
intanto mi metto a correre perchè non
fate un filmato è morta questa piana e
non doveva per avevamo capito che
avresti né servita un cazzo identificati
mi chiamo fa vj piacere quelle creature
se ne vanno in giro e sintetici della
fiction non sono libero.it di merda non
avrei saputo dirlo meglio giuro è un
unità di supporto vitale del quartier
generale andiamo allora tanto come
andare a fare una passeggiata è più o
meno la stessa cosa fatta ma devo
tornare di sopra adesso fantastico
perché tanto più che sono una donna devo
farti cagate no veramente cioè con loro
che sono uomini brutti e grossi no io
faccio io tanto mi sono andata a finire
di qua anzi se ci viviamo nel calcio
anche un po meglio lo posso usare si
fantasia da nadal siccome non so che
cazzo sto facendo clicco a caso infatti
sto mandato da buttare
qualcuno l'ha sa chi è che non staccato
sarà stato mica quel [ __ ] di al 2 va
dentro
no io posso sparargli in faccia vi prego
una volta sola di supplico resta lì
calmo android di merda sono un androide
zio non sconta la leva questo ad usare e
veloce ok loro attivato si vabbè ma non
tornerò mai più la sopra che c'è quel
tizio di merda [ __ ] perché mi devono
far girare i maroni in questa maniera a
lui sa è anche amore nhtsa cioè il ebola
pure chi ce l'ha ucciso è morto nessuno
ha sentito niente vero nessuno ha
sentito niente perfetto cioè ragazzo in
man corsi inscritto in realtà io mi fa
una pippa ma potente possiamo riattivare
qualcosa per favore sii gli atti non si
sia già l'ho fatta adesso che cosa
faccio guardiamo un film non so non
vorrebbe essere qui
android e di merda ragazzi veloci veloci
veloci a fare ecco bravo cazzo un'altra
brutta tua madre brutta non ti ha
aiutato sorella non io [ __ ] ecco
questo ti ha reso più bello di quanto
non lo fossi prima ragazzi dove dove
vado di preciso che non c'è un androide
brutto se c'è qua dentro ragazzi ovvio
mancava vedere gente morta vabbè se sei
bellissimo anche c'è perché sotto torcia
gas
sì però c'è un android che mi sta per
inglobare se fai veloce meglio cazzo tua
madre ma questo sito quanto poi essere
stronzo [ __ ]
sì ho capito sono vivo ancora rimossi
maltrattano le donne [ __ ] che non sei
al no dai veramente c'è un armadietto il
suo posto del cazzo non c'e neanche un
armadietto mi sono [ __ ] da solo non
è che posso andare avanti così no ma che
mira di merda ciò perché
non mi muore sto stronzo lega nostro
cosa farà avete pazienza
sì l'ho preso bye bye bye bye me non lo
prendo si è fatto una sega ecco adesso
si è ucciso
veramente sei morto si è morto grazie a
dio sono riuscito ad uccidere uno liste
teste di cazzo non sono anch'io come
impossibile torcia galafate news a
questa cazzo di torcia perché se no non
ce la faccio mai più
vai vai vai vai vai sì vabbè ma devo
cimento 40 minuti tanto ci avevo tutto
sto tempo da buttare
ovviamente posso tirarla via adesso
perfetto
ci ho messo due ore è un condotto devo
entrare quadra non sia un condotto fa da
filtro nato non vedo una sega metà si si
arrivò zionato giusto perché voi non
sapete fare un cazzo e ci sono dovuto
andare io io posso che c'è della gente
sulla navetta fatemi capire hanno capito
cazzo sono trovato un posto migliore per
saccheggiare ci arriva st navetta
diversi va beh ma prima che arrivi ci
mettono 80 minuti in questo momento mi
servirebbe al in tutta la vita per
ucciderli perché sono troppi ragazzi
fossi già faccio forse forse ce la fa
porca [ __ ]
no io la mia mila di merda io e la mia
mira di merda veloce velocissimo vero
che se gli altri un fatto so che sono io
so che non erano morti qualcosa mi
avrebbero fatto lo so che la gente ci
spar ok perché mi piace c'è qualche
problema
ragazzi ma ma questo sono miei amici per
caso perché sono gli amici sì lo so che
siete voi
ecco no meno male mi sentono tragico
fantastico proprio scalta zio che è che
guardi stato fare si può andare di qua
senza che come star taylor tornerò in
forse non mi chiamano male ci sono
stabiliti no perché mica se continua a
girare così eravamo nella merda è una
cosa che so tizio cos'è parla con
marlowe mar
ok a valigia e piacere nori bley va beh
sì ma un tatuaggio poi anche fartelo
devo andarmene da qui ci mancherebbe
intanto parla voglio sapere tutto i
ragazzi pronti per la fiaba sarà
bellissimo fatemi capire solo un attimo
la caccia il successo che siano i
dirigenti lui ragazzi dove siamo tipo
sta impersonando lui voglio il
significato no veramente adesso vuol
dire che
cos'è sta roba ragazzo siamo nello
spazio
[Musica]
gli emendamenti questo è il pianeta dove
è uscito al giorno ragazzi concludo qui
l'episodio credo che il vino vi sia per
cento massimo i ragazzi servizio è
piaciuto al momento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate la descrizione naso perché di
questa cosa troppo velocemente ma se non
si lavora e si discrete non ci vendiamo
non possiamo vitobello ragazzi